i am here for new music from 98 degrees
bts catches laura scored the exclusive
and you've got the first look
[Music]
y'all are giving me major 90s vibes of
nostalgia with with the cutoffs there
isn't that intentional yes
everything everything from the 90s is
cool again including us so you know it's
it's only fitting
um you know we're not cool we ever step
out of bring back the sleeveless shirts
the bucket hats you know
bag bag your pants the whole nine the
guys look pretty slick in the retro
throwback looks they sport in the video
for their new single
where do you want to
[Music]
it's like go feel good summer party song
you know just if we heard it we're like
man this just sounds like summer
[Music]
98 degrees recorded some of their
upcoming ep in sin
city with some inspo from the king
we actually created our own little
bubble in vegas ironically it was the
old hilton where elvis
used to live and and perform and so we
had it was like this very cool
aura about the place it's the hardest
thing i'll
ever have to do et's been with the boy
band since their early days
their new single drops tomorrow and
expect their other upcoming new songs to
have their signature swag
i think everybody knows to expect a
great love song from 98 degrees
um you know so that's that's kind of
what we focus on there's a spike in
babies being born about you know
a year from now don't blame us the guys
will be hitting the road this summer but
how about
teaming up with backsync the recent
mashup of the backstreet boys and nsync
i don't think you'd have a pop music fan
anywhere that wouldn't want to go see
that show i mean i would want to go see
that show
so i think we would love to see that
[Music]
happening